54% of Americans believe boys are easier
to raise than girls are they and the
polling shows we have felt that way
since the 1940s new CBS end documentary
raising boys explores the challenges
that come with parenting boys today as a
society's idea as society's idea rather
of masculinity changes with ryu growing
up he would wear dresses occasionally
you know and want his nails painted he
was wearing his hair up and sort of a
little samurai ponytail tony was on his
way to school and they'd drop me off at
work and before I got out of the car
when I was getting out and hugs and
kisses and i said hey but i just want
you to know i love your hair I think
it's so cool but kids at school might
not understand and they might say
something about it and he got this look
like he just crestfallen just done and
he took it out and he wouldn't wear it
but it was for me was one of those
things as a parent where I'm like I'm
cool with this the world is not gonna be
okay with this so what do I do and how
do I like protect him or shield him from
to still do the thing he wants to do but
to understand and yeah that kind of like
crushed his spirit that day even though
I thought I was trying to help him it's
a difficult time to be raising boys in
that social norms and expectations are
changing as we speak I feel really bad
for teenage boys and young adult men in
a lot of ways because they grew up in
this world that very much fed them this
one note depiction of masculinity males
are strong males are on top males get
the girls like this is the image that
they were shown over and over and over
on TV in movies in music everywhere that
this was how you are supposed to be so
we've got teenage boys and we've got
young adults who grew up learning one
set of values and now we're in this
process where things are shifting but
we're not fully there yet boy at Adam
Yamaguchi's the executive producer of
CBS and originals and joins us at the
table number one I'm so glad you're
doing this because this is such a new
territory I think for the boys for their
and for all of us to figure this out
yeah you know parents today parents of
young boys today are in uncharted waters
there's no playbook on how to raise boys
who will eventually become men in a post
me to society you think about the the
typical characteristics that define
masculinity today being strong being
dominant being stoic yeah are socialized
into young boys from the day they are
born and so parents are now trying to
try to grapple with well do I do I let
boys be boys but will that lead them to
become aggressive men will get in the
way of them understanding what it is to
be respectful of women and to navigate
their way through a society that's
largely called out bad behaviors yeah
the last time how do you get them out of
what was culturally in the messages they
were hearing into this new era of what
is and what needs to be and and without
damage in the meantime different role
books for the parents sometimes then for
the kids
boys that don't want to be that either
yeah yeah I mean parents are deeply
fearful of emasculating their children
they don't want to go too far so you
know they're grappling with things like
do I let my boys play with action
figures if they're gravitating towards
something else do I let them pick I
think you know how much do I let them be
them as opposed to being forced into
what society thinks they should be and I
mean I'm a good atom thank you very much
Adam Yamaguchi for us the latest CBS n
originals documentary speaking frankly
the series is on raising boys and
streaming right now